- [Kelly] So wait, you recently
called the first round,
Single Jeopardy, instead of just Jeopardy.
So, how did people react to that?
- So the,
on my, I have basically,
clue boards that I review.
- Yeah.
- And the first one does say,
Single Jeopardy,
and the second one says,
Double Jeopardy.
So, I didn't make something
up that doesn't exist.
And people though, lost their minds.
So we usually call it the Jeopardy round.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And yes,
one time we were going,
I think to commercial and,
I think the thing that I'd
like people to remember is
I don't go rogue.
It's never like, "What
is Mayim Bialik saying?"
There's 86 people watching what I'm doing.
If they wanted me to redo it,
I would've been happy to redo it,
but no one said anything.
I just kept talking.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I won't do it again,
'cause it caused a whole
Jeopardy viral situation.
- Oh my God, just so you know,
I think my team gets
nervous because I go rogue.
(both laughing)
- I, no with Jeopardy,
I'm very party line.
Like they're in my ear, I read
the thing, I do the thing.
But obviously that one slipped by.
- Isn't it funny what
people freak out about?
- People care a lot about Jeopardy
and that's very important.
- I know, it is important,
but you almost wanna just like,
start sending them, like real things
that are happening that are important.
And you're like, you know,
like don't even respond.
Just respond with like, I don't know,
there's a lot of homeless people here
we should probably look out for.
Or, I don't know,
there's like real issues,
and I'm always like--
(audience clapping)
Why did you focus on that?
I don't understand,
but whatever.